- Je vous dirais il y a
d'énormes avantages.
On commence avec le pouvoir
d'achat, qui est énorme avec
Lowe's Canada.
- Il y a à peine 10 jours,
le président de Lowe's Canada
vantait encore les bienfaits
pour Rona d'appartenir à
son réseau. Mais voilà
que Lowe's se départit de
ses bannières canadiennes.
JACQUES NANTEL, prof. MTMTMTL et
spécialiste commerce de détail
- Non seulement ils vendent
à rabais, mais c'est carrément
désastreux. C'est une vente de
feu, c'est clair qu'on nettoie
les livres.
- En 2016, Lowe's achetait pour
3,2 millards de dollars, plus de
500 magasieseses bannières Rona,
Réno Dépôt et Dick's Lumber.
En 2022, la société en capital
de risque Sycamore Partners
paie aussi peu que 540 millions
de dollars pour 450 magasins.
L'entente prévoit toutefois
une contrepartie différée
fondée sur le rendement.RIRIRIC.
québ. quincaillerie, matériaux
- Si on est actionnaire chez
Lowe's USA, c'est un échec.
LOUIS HÉBERT, prof. titulaire de
stratégie, HEC Montréal
- Et c'est un échec d'autant
plus, je pense que lorsqu'on
regard f f façon que ça a été
annoncé : en fin de journée,
communiqué de presse, il n'y a
pas nécessairement eu de rumeur.
- Avec la vente, les magasins
canadiens Lowe's deviendront
des  e e et la chaîne
d'approvisonnement restera
intacte, selon Richard Darveau.
- Tous les contrats
d'approvisionnement étaient
signés avec Rona Inc. et
le demeurent. Donc, pour
les gens qui nous écoutent,
bien, j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vont retrouver leurs gammes
de produits auxquels ils sont
habitués et que le nom Rona va
devenir peut-être plus populaire
que jamais.
- C'est d'abord et avant tout
une décision bêtement
financière; c'est-à-dire
quwewewe's a de la difficulté
à aller chercher la même
rentabilité avec ses opérations
au Canada que ce qu'elle réussit
à faire aux États-Unis.
- Le concept des entreprises
affiliées, si cher à Rona,
freine la rentabilité.
- Vous n'êtes pas un grossiste
détaillant, vous ne faites
office que de grossiste et
c'est beaucoup plus difficile,
évidemment, gérer une kyrielle
de petits détaillants.
- Ce changement de main n'a pas
d'impact sur les consommateurs.
- C'est des transactions q
nous dépassent, je ne pense pas
que mon achat aujourd'hui va
faire une grosse différence-.
- Mais certains auraient aimé
que Rona revienne dans le giron
québécois.
- Les gens d'affaires d'ici
auraient pu prendre cette offre.
- Avec la perte de valeur
de l'entreprise, des
investisseurs canadiens
auraient la capacité financière
de racheter la bannière.
Reste à voir s'ils auront
la volonté et quand Sycamore
vendra ses actifs.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montréal